et nous le reprenons avec l'audition
de Gabriel Attal ministre délégué chargé
de comptes publics
donc alors que nous débattrons demain en
séance à la demande de notre commission
de la programmation de nos finances
publiques pour les années
2023 à 2027 à travers le programme de
stabilité et nous est apparu nécessaire
de vous entendre sur l'exécution des
contes de l'année 2022 le gouvernement
en effet présenté en Conseil des
ministres le projet de loi de règlement
du budget d'approbation des comptes de
l'année 2022 en même temps qu'il
redéposait un projet de loi sur
l'exécution des comptes de l'année 2021
après son rejet par le Parlement l'an
passé
nous attendons donc de votre
présentation que vous nous indiquez non
seulement qu'elles ont été les résultats
de l'année passée pour le budget de
l'État mais également dans quelle mesure
ces résultats correspondent aux
estimations de recettes présentées par
le gouvernement et à l'autorisation
parlementaire en dépense qui figurait
dans le collectif budgétaire de fin
d'année les lois de finances ne sont en
effet pas un exercice de pure prévision
elles doivent être sincères au regard
des informations dont dispose le
gouvernement lorsqu'elles sont
présentées
notre commission appuyant cela par la
Cour des comptes a déjà fait des
observations l'an passé sur ce que l'on
peut qualifier parfois de cavalerie
budgétaire par ailleurs j'imagine que
vous nous indiquerez quelle difficulté
concrètes ont pu résulter depuis l'été
dernier de la non-adoption du projet de
la dérèglement pro 2021 et quelle
motivation vous amène à présenter à
nouveau ce texte pour obtenir cette fois
son approbation par le Parlement
dans Monsieur le Ministre sans plus
attendre je vous laisse la parole en
rappelant que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une retransmission sur le site
internet du Sénat ce ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs vous l'avez
dit je serai demain après-midi dans
l'hémicycle pour le débat d'orientation
des finances publiques mais avant de
nous projeter dans les choix
structurants que nous faisons pour les
prochaines années il faut bien sûr
revenir sur l'exécution
budgétaire de l'année antérieure ou
plutôt des années antérieures puisque
comme vous l'avez dit l'originalité de
cette audition et de la période ce sont
deux projets de loi de règlement que
nous devons présenter cette année nous
devons à nouveau présenter le projet de
loi de règlement 2021 puisque celui-ci a
été rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale en
lecture définitive le 3 août dernier
j'étais auditionné il y a quelques jours
par la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale où j'ai redis qu'à
mon sens ne faut pas se tromper de
combat voter un projet de loi de
règlement ou le laisser adopter n'a
jamais voulu dire on donne son accord ou
son satisfait site au gouvernement pour
sa conduite des affaires de la nation
pendant une année donnée mais seulement
qu'on prend acte de l'exécution
budgétaire aire pendant cette année je
fais partie des quelques membres du
gouvernement à être également élus
locaux je conseiller municipal dans ma
commune depuis près de 10 ans dans
l'opposition je crois n'avoir jamais
voté contre un compte administratif
présenté qui donne qui présente les
résultats de l'année antérieure le
projet de loi de règlement c'est une
photo on peut pas changer le passé on
peut essayer de
influer sur l'avenir mais enfin bon je
le dis pas ici puisque ici évidemment le
texte avait été adopté mais donc nous le
représentons il nous présentons bien sûr
la loi de règlement pour l'exercice N-1
c'est-à-dire le projet de loi de
règlement 2022 une année marquée par le
retour d'une très forte inflation au
plan mondial avec des conséquences
importantes sur les conditions dans
lesquelles l'État finance son
endettement s'agissant du projet de loi
de règlement 2021 je veux informer cette
commission des quelques modifications
qui figurent par rapport à la
présentation que nous avons faite l'an
dernier première chose l'article
liminaire a été actualisé suite à la
communication par l'INSEE des contes
2021 survenu le 28 mars dernier
notamment l'actualisation du déficit
2021 à - 6,5% contre 6,4% dans le PLR
2021 qui avait été présenté l'an dernier
c'est notamment dû à la requalification
d'Action Logement dans les
administrations publiques
deuxième chose l'article 6 a été modifié
avec la suppression des dispositions
permettant de ne pas reporter certains
soldes de comptes spéciaux en effet
comme la gestion 2022 a été assurée
l'intégralité de ces soldes a été
reportée comme le prévoit l'article 21
de la LOLF dernière chose l'article 7
relatif à un abandon de créance détenue
sur la Somalie a été supprimé car nous
l'avons repris dans la deuxième loi de
finance rectificative pour 2022 pour
répondre à votre question monsieur le
Président sur l'impact de la
non-adoption définitive du projet de loi
de règlement 2021 on voit que le pays
continue de fonctionner le Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé dans sa décision
sur le PLF 2023 ce que nous pensions
c'est à dire que la seule présentation
est mise au vote à en première lecture
de du projet de loi de règlement 2021
suffisait à ce que l'on puisse adopter
un budget pour les années suivantes il y
a des points assez techniques notamment
de
report de sol sur les comptes spéciaux
par exemple mais en réalité on voit que
ça n'a pas eu d'impact sur l'adoption du
PLF suivant je pense que ça peut amener
d'ailleurs à certaines interrogations
institutionnelles sur l'utilité ou pas
de conserver cette procédure-là s'il
devait y avoir un débat organique moi je
pense que ça peut poser un certain
nombre de questions et qui pourraient y
avoir une forme de débat pour prendre
acte de l'exécution budgétaire en tout
cas ça fait partie je trouve ça
libérerait du temps parlementaire si on
considère que c'est possible ça a pas
empêché que la Cour des comptes certifie
les comptes qui ont été présentés pour
2021 mais c'est un débat que nous aurons
pourquoi est-ce qu'on le représente
parce que je pense que c'est important
pour la sincérité d'autant qu'il y a
quelques évolutions marginales qui sont
intervenus je ne désespère pas que le
texte puisse être adopté puisqu'encore
une fois il ne s'agit que d'une
photographie de ce qui s'est passé dans
l'exercice 2021 on trouve maintenant
dans le vif du sujet avec l'exécution
budgétaire de l'année dernière qui en
vérité peut-être considéré comme une
année de transition
la réalité c'est que nous sommes passés
d'une crise à l'autre de la crise
sanitaire à la crise de l'inflation de
crise mais à chaque fois le choix de
protéger les Français du mieux possible
les entreprises comme les ménages tout
en assurant la maîtrise de nos finances
publiques je ne dis pas que tout va bien
évidemment je dis simplement que nous
avons choisi de protéger et que le pays
a tenu bon d'abord grâce à ces millions
de Français qui travaillent à ces chefs
d'entreprise qui embauchent et qui
investissent je suis bien sûr ici pour
échanger et répondre à vos questions me
permettez-moi de tirer quelques
enseignements concernant l'exécution
budgétaire de l'année dernière le
premier enseignement à tirer je crois
c'est celui de l'efficacité de la
politique économique qui a été conduite
pour protéger face à la crise de
l'inflation pourquoi parce qu'on
s'attaquant au prix de l'énergie avec
les boucliers gaz électricité nous avons
préservé la croissance économique et
donc contribuer au dynamisme des
recettes qui est le principal facteur de
l'amélioration de notre déficit public
au global les recettes ont progressé de
7,3% en 2022 après avoir progressé de
8,4% en 2021
cette croissance des recettes elle
repose principalement sur la progression
de l'impôt sur les sociétés 15,8
milliards d'euros de plus l'an dernier
ce qui nous a permis d'atteindre un
record d'impôt sur les sociétés avec
62,1 milliard d'euros prélevé l'année
dernière alors même que nous avons
diminué le taux à 25 % puisqu'il est
passé de 33 à 25 %. je vais aussi
relever la hausse des recettes d'impôts
sur le revenu plus 10,3 milliards
d'euros notamment grâce au dynamisme de
la masse salariale et de la TVA plus 5,3
milliards d'euros évidemment dans un
contexte d'inflation
comme lors de l'exécution précédente ce
dynamisme des recettes a largement
contribué à la baisse de notre déficit
public qui est passé de 6,5% en 2021 je
le disais à 4,7% l'année dernière donc
la réalité c'est que les choix
économiques que nous avons fait ce sont
révélés également vertueux dans une
certaine mesure d'un point de vue
budgétaire puisque cela nous a permis
d'obtenir des recettes supplémentaires
comme pendant la crise covid nous avons
fait le choix de la protection tout en
poursuivant le redressement des finances
publiques c'est-à-dire en respectant les
bornes que nous avons fixées pour le
retour sous les 3% prévu en 2027 pour
autant et c'est le deuxième enseignement
le sol des administrations publiques
demeure très dégradée précisément parce
que nous avons consacré des moyens
considérables pour casser cette spirale
inflationniste au total pour les années
2021 et 2022 nous avons mis 34,5
milliards d'euros net donc je défalque
et recettes de CSPE et de cris
contribution sur la rentrée marginale
des énergéticiens nous avons mis 34,5
milliards d'euros net sur la table pour
lutter contre l'inflation au travers
principalement des boucliers
énergétiques le montant est considérable
mais la vérité c'est que le coût des
boucliers ce sera toujours moins cher
que les deux points d'inflation que nous
aurions eu en plus si nous les avions
pas mis en place donc c'est un choix que
nous assumons totalement la dernière
chose que je veux dire c'est que nous
devons impérativement tenir nos
objectifs de finances publiques et
enclencher le désendettement de la
France à horizon 2027 comme nous nous y
sommes engagés j'ai conscience que le
défi est de taille la réalité c'est que
les prochaines marches vers les 3%
déficit public à horizon 2027 et même
été ramené on débattra demain dans le
pesta bah 2,7% seront plus difficiles à
franchir parce que l'environnement
économique n'est plus le même en 2022
nous avons été portés par une croissance
de 2,6% celle-ci va s'établir autour de
1% cette année dans un contexte de
ralentissement mondial la conséquence
c'est que notre déficit devrait
s'établir cette année à un niveau proche
de celui de l'année dernière sans doute
légèrement au-dessus de celui la semaine
dernière notre endettement public
devrait toutefois continuer à diminuer
cette année le défi est de taille et
pourtant je sais que nous pouvons y
arriver nous avons une stratégie pour
atteindre nos objectifs cette stratégie
c'est d'abord de poursuivre la sortie du
quoiqu'il en coûte c'est à dire des
dispositifs généraux vers des mécanismes
plus ciblés nous avons commencé à le
faire l'an dernier c'est pas toujours
facile on est sorti par exemple de la
ristourne générale sur le carburant qui
a coûté 8 milliards d'euros sur l'année
2022 pour aller vers une indemnité
carburant ciblée sur les travailleurs et
j'insiste là-dessus les plus modestes
autour de 1 milliard d'euros dans ce qui
a été budgété
ensuite nous devons réaliser des
économies en 2024 et les années et
d'après parce que dans certains secteurs
nous dépensons trop et parfois nous
n'obtenons pas les résultats escomptés
je pense au travail pays qui prend le
chemin du pleinement foi du plein emploi
peut-il se permettre de garder le même
niveau de dépenses que lorsqu'il coulait
sous le chômage de masse la question se
pose légitimement évidemment nous y
travaillons avec mes collègues je pense
enfin à certaines dépenses brunes
notamment fiscales qui ne démontre plus
leur efficacité qui ne sont plus en
ligne avec notre ambition écologique et
dans chaque budget de manière
transversale nous continuerons à
maîtriser les dépenses et à compter
chaque euro pour que la dépense publique
augmente moins vite que sa tendance
naturelle j'insiste sur le fait que la
première ministre a décidé un courrier à
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
leur demandant d'identifier 5% de marge
de manœuvre dans le budget de leur
ministère pour préparer les travaux
budgétaires pour 2024 et les années
suivantes
comme l'année dernière je veux que
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
représentés au Parlement soit associé à
cette réflexion et plus largement au
processus d'élaboration la prochaine loi
de finances c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous proposerai de reprendre
l'exercice des dialogues de Bercy avec
cette année une première série de
réunions délétée donc en anticipant donc
par rapport à l'année dernière j'avais
dit que c'était une version bêta au sens
une première version qui permettent de
tester les choses je pense qu'on peut
aller plus loin améliorer le dispositif
nous voulons aller vers davantage de
co-construction il faut avoir davantage
de temps pour échanger pour expertiser
pour arbitrer donc nous pourrons
commencer plutôt ce travail cette année
voilà pour la présentation synthétique
et je me tiens à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
merci Monsieur le Ministre oui je
voudrais vous dire simplement que vous
souhaitez sincèrement que le Sénat vote
la loi de règlement 2021 parce que
contrairement à ce que vous avez pu dire
le Sénat ne l'avait pas voté ni
l'Assemblée nationale ni le Sénat mais
on a compris que c'est un espèce
d'encouragement
à faire différemment cette année bien
monsieur le rapporteur général
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le président
je vais juste rebondir sur le votre
propos final monsieur le ministre
va falloir que vous changiez comment
dirais-je un peu le la conjonction
astrale parce que vous voulez la qu'on
construction tout en faisant un appel à
la consultation publique
pour savoir ce que les Français
attendent de l'utilisation de l'impôt
donc vous allez avoir des je pense à moi
des difficultés pour
mettre tout ça sur les rails je voulais
très rapidement
aborder trois à quatre sujets au sujet
d'abord de l'exécution budgétaire dont
je relève que cette année encore elle
est très éloignée de la prévision alors
c'est pas dû à des dépenses
exceptionnelles loin sans faux je
rappelle juste que
au dernier PLFR de 2022 il était prévu
des recettes fiscales nettes un peu plus
de 315 milliards elles ont été de
323,3 milliards la Cour des comptes
d'ailleurs a bien souligné que c'était
je le disais pas des événements
exceptionnels c'est finalement un effet
répétitif est-ce que on peut connaître
les raisons pour lesquelles votre
ministère a des difficultés désormais à
prévoir les recettes fiscales et de
quelle manière vous souhaitez vous y
prendre pour faire en sorte que les
prévisions soient beaucoup plus
conformes enfin où les réalisations à
vos prévisions je vais aborder un
deuxième sujet qu'il a est récurrent et
préoccupant c'est celui des records
massifs de crédit et ceux depuis 2021 si
je reprends le budget de 2022 il y a un
écart qui est je le dis préoccupant
entre les crédits approuvés par la loi
de finances initiale et les crédits
effectivement mis à disposition
des ministres
la loi de finances pour 2022 avait
ouvert
392 milliards de crédit au remboursement
des grèvements
ceux-ci ont été portés à 440 milliards
au fil de collectifs budgétaires
auxquels se sont ajoutés 23 milliards
d'euros via des reports de crédit
et au total les dépenses exécutées ne se
sont élevées qu'à 446 milliards de
crédit c'est-à-dire que les reports vont
quasiment pas été utilisés et que donc
ils auraient pu être évités et malgré le
constat que je fais la pratique se
poursuit puisque 17 milliards de crédit
ont à nouveau été reportés de 2022 à
la loi de finances ne donne donc
désormais qu'une vision imprécise de la
réalité du budget ce qui me semble-t-il
réduit la portée de l'autorisation
parlementaire quand est-ce que vous
comptez sortir de cette stratégie
j'appellerai du flou et pourquoi ne pas
mettre fin à cette pratique de report
massif de crédit pour revenir à des
montants beaucoup plus raisonnables
troisième sujet qui a fait
l'objet d'une attention particulière de
notre assemblée c'est l'exécution du
filet de sécurité que nous avons voté au
premier pelletfair de l'été 2022 au
bénéfice donc des collectivités locales
et de leurs groupements
donc il y avait deux premiers critères
retenus l'épargne brut au 31 décembre
2021 inférieur à 22% des recettes
réelles de fonctionnement et le
potentiel financier ou fiscal inférieur
au double à la moyenne de la strate et
il y avait donc théoriquement
18521 communes éligibles 944 EPCI à ce
filet de sécurité soit respectivement 53
et 75% des collectivités concernées au
regard des dernières données en cours de
finalisation sur les comptes de gestion
de 2022 quel est à date votre estimation
du nombre de communes et de PC qui
remplissent le troisième critère de
baisse d'épargne brute de 25% entre 2021
et 2022
par ailleurs 106 millions d'euros et 430
millions ont été ouverts en LFR et ils
ont été consommés pour le paiement des
acomptes peut vous nous dire combien de
communes et de Pessi ont finalement
demandé le versement de cet acompte et
qu'elle en était le montant moyen la
dotation doit être versée d'ailleurs au
plus tard au 30 octobre de cette année
avez-vous donc déjà reçu des demandes
vous nous aviez expliqué que certaines
communes ou collectivités gardaient la
faculté 2 dans l'affirmative combien de
communes et de PC et on fait cette
demande à partir de leur donner
financières définitive et enfin Monsieur
le Ministre pouvait nous dire s'agissant
du plan de relance
où on en est sur les versements attendus
de la part de l'Union européenne au
titre de la mise en œuvre du plan de
relance
merci Monsieur laporteur général écoutez
ça fait une bonne petite série pour
démarrer très bien et puis je donnerai
la parole après à mes collègues alors
merci beaucoup pour cette première série
de questions effectivement il y a des
recettes qui se sont élevées à un
montant plus important
exécuté que ce qui avait été prévu y
compris dans la dernière LFR 2022 si je
prends dans le dans le détail par
rapport à la LFR 2 2022 les recettes
d'impôt sur les sociétés ont surpris à
la hausse avec 3,2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires enfin d'années en raison
d'un rendement plus élevé qu'attendu de
la compte de décembre et du solde sur
l'impôt sur le revenu une plus-value de
1,6 milliards d'euros avec je le disais
tout à l'heure un fort dynamisme de la
masse salariale et enfin sur la TVA en
comptabilité nationale la TVA serait
moins élevée de 1,9 milliards d'euros au
niveau anticipé en L FR2 parce qu'il y a
une plus-value budgétaire d'un milliard
mais qui est plus que compensé par la
correction de droit constaté de
milliards d'euros on cherche toujours à
être au plus juste et on a se débat
régulièrement à chaque audition c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle d'être surpris
dans ce sens là il faut aussi voir qu'on
a une croissance qui c'est plus que
tenue en 2022 en 2023 on maintient notre
objectif à 1% de croissance et un
certain nombre de prévisions récentes
ont réévalué la prévision qu'elle
faisait pour la France sans la porter à
1% mais en tout cas se rapprochant du
1%, ce qui je crois souligne qu'on a
raison d'être volontariste en la matière
mais donc nécessairement je pense qu'on
sera moins surpris à la hausse qu'on a
pu l'être l'an dernier sur les report
massif effectivement ils sont importants
j'essaye de voir le verre à un
tiers-plan ils sont très importants
encore ils le sont un peu moins que
l'année précédente on est un peu au
dessus de 18 milliards d'euros de
reports ce qui est beaucoup je rappelle
que l'année précédente c'était au-dessus
de 23 milliards d'euros on est très loin
de ce qu'on soit à quoi on est habitué
en termes de report en rythme de
croisière plutôt autour de 3 à 5
milliards d'euros donc on est très
au-dessus ce qui est certain c'est que
on a visé large et ouvert beaucoup de
crédit face à la crise de l'inflation
pour être capable de protéger notamment
sur les dépenses du guichet pour les
entreprises énergo intensives ou un
certain nombre un grand nombre des fonds
n'ont pas été consommés en 2022 d'où le
report en 2023 sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui ont été ouverts
d'ailleurs à la demande des
parlementaires pour soutenir un certain
nombre de ménages avec je pense à l'aide
fioul à l'aide bois qui n'ont pas été
consommés en 2022 et donc ils sont
reportés en 2023 il y a des restes à
payer du plan de relance notamment lié à
des travaux de rénovation énergétique
qui ont pris un peu de retard sur des
dépenses on va dire non liées à la crise
un des principaux facteurs de reports
notamment le plan d'investissement dans
les compétences la part régionale du pic
autour de 1,9 milliards d'euros avec des
reports très importants dans certaines
régions je pense notamment à la région
Île-de-France où on est proche des 800
millions d'euros de crédit qui sont
reportés en 2023 ce sont des fonds du
plan d'investissement dans les
compétences pour la part régionale qui
n'ont pas été décaissés par les régions
[Musique]
en question et donc ça fait partie aussi
de ce qui explique les différents
reports sur la question sur le filet de
sécurité
au 31 mars
2023 le dernier la dernière prévision
que les services ont cherché à faire un
grand nombre de collectivités n'avaient
pas encore rendu leur compte de gestion
clôturé leur compte de gestion 2022
on aura une première estimation très
fine plutôt au mois de juin 2022 ce
qu'on peut voir c'est que le nombre de
communes et de PCI qui seront qui auront
été effectivement éligibles au filet de
sécurité pour l'année 2022 a priori sera
supérieur à ceux qui ont reçu un acompte
pour cela je peux pas vous donner
exactement le chiffre puisque je ne veux
pas m'avancer tant qu'on n'a pas encore
l'ensemble des données sur les comptes
de gestion des collectivités locales si
finalement il y a moins de communes que
ce qui était attendu ça veut dire qu'il
y a moins de communes qui ont vu une
perte de CAF de l'ampleur de ce qui
avait été prévu dans le dispositif voté
pour le coup celui-ci par le Parlement
et par les deux Chambres donc ça serait
plutôt une bonne nouvelle entre
guillemets ça veut dire qu'il y a moins
de communes ou de PCI qui sont trouvées
en situation de devoir demander le filet
de sécurité mais avant d'avoir la vérité
sur les prix je préfère qu'on dispose de
l'ensemble des données et je serai
évidemment à la disposition du Sénat et
d'ailleurs je vous transmettrai avant
même qu'il y a une audition ou un
échange dans l'hémicycle sur le sujet
toutes les données dont on dispose
sur l'exécution des filets
au 31 mars aussi sur les deux on avait
encore pas toutes les manquer encore de
beaucoup d'informations sur un certain
nombre de collectivités ce que je vous
dis c'est qu'au 31 mars les premières
données dont on dispose semble indiquer
que on aura davantage de communes et de
PCI éligibles au filet de sécurité que
de ceux qui avaient demandé un acompte
avant la fin de l'année 2022 j'aimerais
pouvoir être plus précis on a eu on a eu
4100 non on a eu un peu plus de 4100
acomptes qui ont été versés en 2022 ce
que je vous dis c'est qu'on aura
davantage de communes et de PCI
effectivement bénéficiaires du final de
sécurité
en fonction des données dont on
disposait sur les clôtures de contes de
gestion maintenant faut quand même que
les collectivités puissent avoir
clôturer leur compte de gestion et qu'on
puisse regarder et qu'elle puisse
regarder effectivement ou non elles sont
éligibles au fil de sécurité pour
pouvoir avoir un chiffrage très précis
sur la question du plan de relance la
France pour recevoir jusqu'à 40,3
milliards d'euros de subventions dans le
cadre du pnlr c'est 37,5 milliards de
subventions au titre de la FRR et 2,8
milliards d'euros de subventions au
titre du programme ripower u depuis
l'adoption du PNR français en 2021 la
France a reçu deux versements à ce stade
pour un montant total de 12,5 milliards
d'euros 5,1 milliard d'euros de
préfinancement en août 2021 suite à
l'adoption de notre pnrr et 7,4
milliards d'euros a été perçu en mars
2022 suite au dépôt de la première
demande de paiement en novembre 21
donc voilà pour les les données que nous
on dispose sur les versements du plan de
relance européen
merci Monsieur le Ministre
[Musique]
Jérôme Bacher puis Isabelle briquet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre revenons sur l'épisode 2021 vu
que vous voulez y revenir volontiers
je de mémoire mais nous on avait dû
s'abstenir et ça devait être la gauche
qui avait du voté contre au Sénat la loi
de c'est important et pourquoi on
s'était absolu dites une photographie
oui c'est une photographie mais c'est la
photographie si vous voulez du radar sur
la route vous avez été pris en excès de
report et donc
de ne pas avoir respecté la LOLF juste
la loi ne respectez pas la loi organique
la loi ne respectait pas la loi
organique et bis répéta non placette en
l'occurrence
et c'est là où ça va plus
si nous votons à PLF dans lequel pour
vous nous dites il y a de l'inflation il
faut prévoir des mesures nous avons
discuter huit amont
mais qu'en vérité vous gardez un petit
matelas une épargne de précaution
dirait-on sauf que celle-ci existe déjà
monsieur le ministre dans la loi
organique voulu ici à l'époque par un
Lambert
c'est la réserve de précaution elle
existe déjà vous l'utilisez mal
donc vous l'utilisez deux fois ce n'est
pas l'esprit de la loi organique ce
n'est même pas l'esprit de la loi
organique que nous avons voté ici
voulu par vos amis politiques
principalement l'initiative de
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'elle nous
avons travaillé de conserve histoire qui
est
en décembre 2021 un accord sur cette
réforme est de la loi organique Lambert
nigaud et donc c'est pour cela que nous
sommes plus à d'accord avec ces lois de
règlement ce ne sont pas des photos
comme vous le dites simplement ce sont
des photos de d'excès de pouvoir
et c'est bien cela que nous vous
reprochons profondément sur ces lois de
règlement c'est ce que je voulais vous
dire simplement donc comment voulez-vous
que on vous dise ah oui il y a
l'inflation faut qu'on prévoit un peu
plus c'est dans le budget ou alors on
représente une loi de règlement le
pardon une loi rectificative excusez moi
pour modifier en conséquence avec de
nouvelles dispositions c'est comme cela
qu'il faut faire et c'est à cela que je
vous demande dorénavant de prendre acte
merci Jérôme Isabelle briquet puis
Stéphane sauterelle
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre trois petits trois petits
points concernant le règlement pour un
pour 2021 vous l'avez rappelé ce texte a
été rejeté donc il y a-t-il des
évolutions permettant l'adoption de ce
texte parce que sans évolution ou à mal
comment nous pourrions changer notre
braquet sur le projet de dérèglement
pour 2022 fin cycle a rappelé le
rapporteur tout à l'heure le rapporteur
général sont à noter des reports de
crédit très important également sur 2023
donc vous nous dites que effectivement
c'est c'est cette habituel c'est même un
petit peu moins que l'année est passée
mais justement est-il envisagé de
limiter cette pratique qui nuit quand
même à la lisibilité des comptes puisque
l'amélioration du solde résulte
grandement de ses reports et non
d'économie sur un sur 2022
[Musique]
ensuite comme vous nous présentez un
nouveau projet de loi de règlement pour
pourtant rejeter que l'heure est à la
présentation du programme de stabilité
étant donné le contenu de ce programme
de stabilité comptez-vous nous présenter
une nouvelle loi de programmation des
finances publiques puisque là aussi nous
l'avons nous l'avons rejeté et juste un
petit un tout petit point
je peux des fois un petit peu voilà un
tout petit point puisqu'on a parlé du
filet de sécurité ce qu'il serait
intéressant aussi de connaître c'est que
le nombre de collectivités qui ont été
sollicités pour un parler par les DGFiP
en leur disant vous pouvez déposer vous
êtes rentré dans les clous vous avez
vous pouvez bénéficier du filet de
sécurité à qui on a versé un acompte et
qui maintenant sont rattrapés par la
patrouille si je puis dire où la même
DGFiP leur dit bah écoutez
vous ne rentrez plus dans les critères
alors est-ce qu'il y a une évolution des
critères ou est-ce que il y a eu un
emballement un petit peu pour proposer à
certaines collectivités de
bénéficier de ces acomptes parce que la
restitution mais les un de ces acomptes
mais certaines communes en difficulté
voilà merci
merci Isabelle Stéphane Sautarel
simulation le ministre sans revenir sur
l'ensemble des éléments portant sur
cette loi de règlement macro et en
particulier le rendement des recettes et
le respect de la Golf a évoqué Jérôme
Bacher très largement je vais revenir
sur trois points le premier dans le
droit fil de ce qui a déjà évoqué le
rapporteur général sur
le fameux filet de sécurité la situation
des collectivités parce que la lecture
semble à cette heure très très
contrastée et on peut s'interroger si
justement la responsabilité dans les
collectivités ont pu faire preuve y
compris dans une situation difficile
fait que moi je crains plutôt qui allait
beaucoup qui soit évité dans les dans
les interventions finales et que
certaines collectivités qui ont demandé
des avances se trouvent aujourd'hui dans
des situations difficiles et notamment
par rapport à ce fameux critère de
l'épargne brute qui
d'évoquer d'ailleurs lors de son
adoption nous semblait un peu exorbitant
et et surtout des responsabilisants et
je pense que les collectivités auront
largement fait preuve de responsabilité
malgré les difficultés et donc je crains
que ce filet de sécurité 2022
ne soit en fait plus un effet d'annonce
qu'une qu'un réel appui aux collectivité
mais sous réserve des éléments que vous
pourrez nous produire mais les
témoignages que j'ai sont à la fois
aujourd'hui sur le terrain de
difficultés accrues des collectivités et
en même temps de s'en sacrer des
responsabilités qui font que elle
s'exonère pour partir où elles sortent
en tout cas de de mailles du filet qui
étaient un peu trop un peu trop large le
deuxième remarque porte sur vous l'avez
largement évoqué on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir dans d'autres cadres sur le
niveau d'endettement et et donc la
question que je voulais vous poser c'est
de savoir si vous n'aviez pas
l'intention
au regard des résultats de cette loi de
règlement plus favorable d'avoir une
action de désendettement qui pourrait
être accéléré au regard de la situation
que vous nous présentez et qui en termes
de rendement de certaines recettes et
plus favorable que ce qui était escompté
et donc s'il y avait pas là aussi
puisqu'il y a beaucoup de signes
aujourd'hui attendus dans un sens ou
dans un autre une action particulière
sur la dette qui serait permise par
cette loi de règlement et puis ma
troisième question
et plus sur la dépense parce que
globalement le périmètre de de la
dépense dans cette loi de règlement
montre qui qui a une insuffisance ou une
absence de de maîtrise et que l'objectif
de de réduire justement à la fois le
déficit et l'endettement par une
meilleure maîtrise de la dépense n'est
guère engagée dans cette loi de
règlement et aujourd'hui encore même si
vous affichez la sortie du du quoi qu'il
en coûte on est quand même surpris par
quelques annonces qui demeure et qui
crée quelques troubles dans la lecture
qu'on peut avoir de cette réduction de
la dépense merci
merci Stéphane en attendant d'éventuels
autre question de nos collègues
peut-être quelques quelques remarques
tout d'abord vous avez cité avec un art
de la litote tout à fait tout à fait
clair et de qualité
le fait de revoir la ristourne
généralisée sur les carburants que vous
avez cité à 8 milliards d'euros bon on
peut se le dire entre nous monsieur le
ministre c'était pas une très bonne idée
bon elle est venue de l'Assemblée
nationale
on le sait
nationale oui mais sans vouloir parler
pour les LR du Sénat comment dirais pas
beaucoup de soutien cette mesure ici bon
voilà de manière générale mais en tout
cas je vais parler pour une autre partie
qui est clairement été contre c'est à
dire qu'il est considéré que sans doute
il valait mieux
cibler les publics en avaient le plus
plutôt que de dépenser largement pour
une dépense qui était d'une certaine
façon un acronique en plus financer le
carburant sincèrement j'aurais pas donné
la parole à notre collègue vert ici mais
je suis sûr qu'il pourrait nous en faire
un quart d'heure sans problème pour
expliquer que c'était totalement
anachronique donc je note quand même que
vous le relevez pas une mesure très une
mesure très heureuse voilà donc
par exemple voilà 8 milliards peut-être
qu'avec un milliard judicieusement posé
vous placer on pouvait sans doute faire
aussi bien ou peut-être même mieux plus
utile en tout cas voilà pour un premier
sujet donc ce sont des sujets quand même
à quelques milliards et sans doute en
cherchant ici ou là on pourrait on
pourrait retrouver mais comme celui-là
vous l'avez cité je me permets de dire
vous avez également dit est-ce qu'il
faut encore présenter de loi de
règlement
bon je voudrais juste vous dire
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on a évoqué le
problème de la réforme de la LOLF voulu
voulu par par Bercy avec un député un
président favorable prêt à porter cette
réforme de la Golf et dans la réforme de
l'OLF on aurait pu envisager la
suppression de loi de règlement mais
c'est pas ce qui a été dit c'est plutôt
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que les lois de
règlement vont effectivement disparaître
mais pour être en fait rebaptisé votre
rebaptisé alors je le répète parce que
ça va ça nous paraissait bien le droit
de règlement parce que cours
baptisé en loi relative aux résultats de
la gestion et pourtant approbation des
contes de l'année
je cite c'est ce que nous avons
finalement voté
j'allais dire monsieur le rapporteur
général bon gré malgré bon enfin en tout
cas ça paraissait être une question
fondamentale donc nous l'avons voté mais
si je comprends bien on vient de voter
ces nouvelles lois mais vous souhaitez
les voir disparaître si je comprends
bien bon j'y vois je vois une petite
enfin si vous avez un commentaire à nous
faire là-dessus voilà donc on trouve ça
un petit peu un peu imaginez que c'est
un petit peu paradoxal malgré tout et
puis j'en ai une j'en ai une troisième
[Musique]
c'est que est-ce que mais alors la
culture monde technique et puis pour on
est début mais donc pouvez-vous nous
indiquer des aujourd'hui si un décret
d'avance ou une loi de finance
rectificative risque de s'avérer
nécessaire d'ici à l'été notamment parce
que comme le disait notre colère
sautarène
il y a des annonces bon alors il y a des
fois des annonces qui sont
immédiates pour des budgets qui viennent
plus tard ça on le sait bien cela étant
dit le ministre des armées a indiqué
dans la presse qui n'était pas
supplémentaire de 1,5 milliards d'euros
serait nécessaire au titre de 2023 un
évoquant rectificatif budgétaire pour le
budget des armées
et puis même l'inflation pourrait être à
l'origine d'autres demandes l'âge cité
le ministre des Armées non
vous avez cette même traduction
rectificatif budgétaire juste lié aux
armées ou au contraire plutôt une loi de
finance rectificative qu'est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire sur le sujet
alors je réponds à la première série de
questions en commençant par celle du
président rénale évidemment
sur l'aristo mais est-ce que c'était une
erreur
on a toujours assumé que c'était
temporaire
c'est effectivement une mesure qui a été
qui a fait l'objet d'un accord avec le
groupe LR de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
permis l'adoption du projet de loi de
finance rectificative du pack à pouvoir
d'achat à l'été 2022
je regrette pas cette mesure je dis je
pense qu'elle a apporté un soutien
temporaire au moment où la crise de
l'inflation faisait monter les prix du
carburant extrêmement fort moi je vois
aussi je le dis en me déplaçant sur le
terrain en échangeant comme vous tous
avec des Français
qui a une forme de colère ou de
ressentiment d'une partie des Français
qui travaillent face à des dispositifs
qui parfois en étant ciblées cibles
avant tout des Français qui ne
travaillent pas parce que ce sont les
plus précaires et qui disent finalement
quand on met en place des dispositifs
ils ne sont jamais destinés on voit
passer des aides on voit passer des
chèques je vais au bout de mon
développement oui mais vous aviez
proposé vous aviez pas proposé ça vous
avez proposé pour les gens qui
travaillent je suis d'accord c'est ce
que je dis au début on avait prévu une
indemnité carburant du fait d'un accord
avec les LR à l'Assemblée nationale on a
mis en place la ristourne pour tout le
monde vous me demandiez si je regrettais
à posteriori finalement je le regrette
pas je pense que ça a apporté un soutien
un coup de pouce y compris à des
Français qui malheureusement ont parfois
un peu pris l'habitude ou le sentiment
que le soutien public est avant tout
dirigé vers d'autres queues alors même
qui travaillent qui sont des difficultés
qui doivent prendre leur voiture pour
aller travailler avaler un certain
nombre de kilomètres et donc je pense
qu'avoir des mesures qui leur sont aussi
destinées c'est ça leur montre que quand
il y a des coups durs quand il y a des
crises les pouvoirs publics sont aussi
là pour eux voilà c'est pour ça
typiquement sur l'inflation alimentaire
qui a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup de Français le fait qu'on ait
un dispositif qui évidemment perfectible
qui règle évidemment pas tous les
problèmes mais de trimestres
anti-inflation qui s'adressent à tous
les consommateurs qui le souhaitent me
semblent plus favorable qu'une aide
ciblée sur des Français parce que encore
une fois on a beaucoup de Français qui
aujourd'hui cette politique d'échecs et
du soutien ciblé voilà je pense qu'on
atteint une certaine limite de ce point
de vue là sur les projets de loi de
règlement je vais être très clair je ne
préconise pas leur suppression je dis
simplement que à partir du moment où
un rejet du texte je crois que c'était
la première fois qu'un projet de loi de
règlement était rejeté depuis la
Monarchie de Juillet que tout le monde
se demandait ce qui allait se passer
qu'on se rend compte que ça ne fait pas
obstacle à la présentation du PLF
suivant ni à la certification des
comptes et que manifestement les
oppositions ne souhaitent pas permettre
l'adoption de ce projet de loi de
réglement quand bien même on ne peut
rien changer dans un projet de loi de
règlement ce qui ne fait que prendre
acte de ce qui s'est passé je trouve la
question se pose une prix pour du temps
parlementaire mais c'est pas du tout il
y a pas du tout de décision en ce sens
d'orientation on pourrait répondre à
Madame briquet qui demandait s'il y a
des changements dans le projet de loi de
règlement qui pourrait vous faire
changer dans votre vote si vous avez
voté contre le projet de loi de
règlement parce que vous êtes en
désaccord avec les choix politiques et
budgétaires du gouvernement sur l'année
2021 j'ai envie de vous dire que je suis
pas sûr que ça change je peux pas les
changer moi j'aimerais pouvoir entrer
dans une DeLorean et retourner en 2021
pour changer un certain nombre de choses
je peux pas le faire donc c'est le
projet de loi de règlement il vient
juste dire ce qui s'est passé en 2021
voilà donc faut pas changer ce qui s'est
passé essayer d'en tirer des
enseignements pour l'avenir mais voilà
j'espère quand même qu'il pourra être
adopté encore une fois
si je prends ensuite les questions dans
l'ordre
monsieur cherche entendu vos remarques
je pense que dans un moment de crise
calibrer des dispositifs pour être sûr
de ne pas se retrouver en situation
difficile pour l'aide au boulanger pour
l'aide sur le fioul pour l'être sur le
bois je pense que c'est de bonnes
gestion mais évidemment l'objectif je
l'ai dit c'est de ramener c'est de
ramener les reports à un niveau le plus
faible possible moi je le redis et
d'ailleurs ils sont plus faibles en
20002 qu'il était en 2021 madame briquet
il y avait d'autres questions donc sur
les report j'ai répondu oui on veut
limiter cette pratique sur la LPF la
première ministre dans sa feuille de
route a annoncé qu'elle serait
représentée à l'été au mois de juillet
donc et vous avez dit que vous l'aviez
que le Sénat l'avait rejeté là pour le
coup autant tout à l'heure j'ai dit que
le Sénat avait adopté le projet de loi
de règlement effectivement c'était une
abstention de la majorité sanatoriale et
donc le texte avait été rejeté autant
sur le sur la LPFP elle a été adoptée
dans une version qui n'est pas celle qui
était présentée par le gouvernement elle
est toujours
là parmi nous j'ai envie de se dire
dans une forme de lévitation et elle va
revenir elle va revenir parce que la
première ministre l'a annoncé d'autant
qu'on a et on fera l'objet du débat
qu'on a demain revu la trajectoire dans
le cadre du programme de stabilité
trajectoire plus ambitieuse et là je
réponds à Monsieur
sottarel notamment avec qui a parlé de
désendettement accéléré en tout cas on
accélère le rythme qui était prévu de
retour sous les 3% et de désendettement
puisque la première le programme de
stabilité l'an dernier et la LPF
prévoyait un déficit à 2,9% en 2027 on
est passé à 2,7% et sur le ratio d'être
sur PIB on accélère également pour avoir
une diminution de l'année 2026
je viens ensuite donc sur la LPF elle
sera représentée on aura à nouveau le
débat sur le filet de sécurité
collectivité locale 2022 effectivement
il peut se trouver des situations où des
collectivités locales ont demandé ce
sont vus versés un acompte et en réalité
la situation exécutée en 2022 fait
qu'elles ont eu une perte de CAF moins
importante que ce qui était dans les
critères du filet de sécurité on aura
encore une fois la vérité sur les prix
au mois de juin mais j'ai vu que le
rapporteur général souhaitait que je
sois plus précis et donc j'ai pu avoir à
nouveau quelques quelques chiffres avec
80% des comptes de gestion remontés on a
4838 collectivités qui peuvent
bénéficier du filet de sécurité donc on
est au-dessus du nombre de collectivités
qui ont pu recevoir un acompte puisqu'il
y avait 4178 collectivités qui ont reçu
un incompte fin 2022 donc on est déjà à
près de 700 de plus que celle qui avait
reçu un acompte en 2022 je pense que
dedans il y a des collectivités qui
n'avaient pas demandé d'acompte qui en
fait bénéficie du filet de sécurité et
de l'autre il y a des collectivités qui
avaient demandé un acompte qui en
réalité n'en bénéfice pas au regard des
critères dont je rappelle qu'ils ont été
fixés par le Parlement c'est un
amendement de votre collègue madame
pires Boone à l'Assemblée nationale qui
a fixé le dispositif et les critères ont
ensuite été et ce dispositif a été
adopté à l'unanimité des groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale il a ensuite été
parfait au Sénat notamment par les
travaux de la majorité sénatoriale mais
avec l'ensemble des groupes et on a
arrivé à une situation avec un filet de
sécurité avec des critères 25% de perte
de CAF une CAF un niveau de CAF qui
était prévu au début de l'année 2022
pour entrer dans le dispositif s'il y a
moins de communes que ce qui aurait pu
être envisagé dans le dispositif ça veut
dire qu'il y a moins de communes qui ont
eu une perte de CAF d'une importance
supérieure à 25% ce qui est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour ces communes voilà
moi ce que j'ai dit aux Directions
Départementales des finances publiques
pour que vous le sachiez puisque
j'imagine vous avez des communes qui
vous ont alerté sur ce sujet là c'est
évidemment dès lors qu'il y a un filet
de sécurité qui a été voté pour 2023 de
pas demander à des collectivités qui
auraient reçu un acompte pour 2022 et
qui ne rentre pas dans les critères en
2022 de rendre l'argent en 202 attendons
déjà de voir si éventuellement ces
communes sont éligibles au filet de
sécurité 2023 dans les critères ont été
revus entre guillemets en les
assouplissant pour qu'il y ait davantage
de communes qui en bénéficient puisqu'on
n'est plus à 25% de perte de CAF mais à
15%, je crois et donc voilà évidemment
l'objectif c'est pas de déstabiliser les
collectivités locales mais on y verra
plus clair en juin prochain
sur ensuite ben non je crois que j'ai
fait un peu le tour des différentes
questions qui ont été posées et le PFP
j'ai répondu trajectoire j'ai répondu
filet de sécurité aussi
je crois que je vous ai posé une
question sur décret d'avance ou la
technique mais attendez un peu on va si
vous permettez je vais donner la parole
à Monsieur Vincent Segoin qui va vous
poser une peut-être une dernière série
de questions et vous répondrai à
l'enfant
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre
alors ma première question elle est
autant destinée au ministre au président
vous avez dit dans votre démonstration
que la baisse du taux de l'IS entraîne à
entraîner une hausse des recettes de
l'IS est-ce à dire que trop d'impôts tu
l'impôt
le deuxième question c'est le
sentez que ça allait inspirer le la
deuxième question c'est le coût du
chèque carburant vous avez dit que ça
coûtait 8 milliards d'euros mais je
voulais juste savoir quelles étaient
réelles les recettes réelles pour l'État
lié à l'augmentation du carburant
[Musique]
on a on a eu déjà c'est pour ça que la
question a été posée mais il m'a été
adressée aussi ce qui n'est pas la règle
on a quelques minutes
sur cette question de finalement il y a
plus de recettes d'ailleurs c'est un
débat qui a eu lieu pendant le débat sur
les retraites vous souvenez sur la
question est-ce que le fait d'avoir plus
de recettes fiscales traduis le fait que
en baissant l'impôt en a finalement plus
de plus de comment dire l'économie se
porte mieux et donc et donc il y a plus
de recettes fiscales c'est un sujet qui
mériterait en tout cas d'être étudié de
près pour des raisons très différentes
d'abord le montant dont il est question
je l'ai rappelé il y a 10 ans déjà en
été dans ces montants là lorsqu'on avait
un taux de 33% donc on fait aujourd'hui
un peu mieux avec 60 milliards un peu
mieux que ce qu'on faisait il y a 10 ans
en termes de produits fiscal sur les
entreprises avec 33%
bien si on compte l'inflation entre
temps et l'inflation surtout d'ailleurs
dans la dernière année on se rend compte
que bon pas quelque chose de très très
différent la réalité c'est que si on
voulait montrer l'intérêt de la chose et
j'espère qu'il y ait pour une partie en
tout cas il faudra attendre quelques
années de plus pourquoi parce que si on
ne perçoit pas l'impôt les entreprises
ont plus donc de ressources et la
question c'est est-ce que ces ressources
passent à l'investissement et ensuite se
traduisent par une augmentation de leur
chiffre d'affaires c'est ça la réalité
et de leur marge et donc après si
margilia il y a un position
supplémentaire je pense que dire que
deux ans après une mesure par exemple
et avec une crise en plus majeure au
milieu on peut mesurer ce type d'effet
je pense que pour partie il existe mais
pour partie seulement voilà donc c'est
un débat qu'on peut avoir à cette
technique deuxième aspect c'est que dans
les valeurs récentes il y a eu la crise
et donc les entreprises ont anticipé des
acomptes faibles donc on a eu des années
avec acompte faible parce qu'elle
pensait qu'avec les crises de
successives en particulier évidemment la
pandémie en premier mais également il y
a l'énergie également elles allaient
avoir moins de résultats que nous
d'ailleurs c'est une surprise tout le
monde l'a dit partager la résilience de
l'économie française ça a été un peu une
surprise d'une certaine façon par sa
dimension bon et donc effectivement la
question se pose toujours dans ces
cas-là de savoir s'il y a pas eu des
acomptes et ça a été la réalité les
entreprises ont mis des acomptes plus
faibles ensuite elles ont mis des
montants et ensuite elles ont finalement
vous savez que c'est en trois phases
donc elles ont ensuite comment dire
payer l'impôt final et donc qu'est-ce
qui est dû au fait que désaccords
étaient faibles dans le fait que le
produit était plus dans les années
précédentes et donc Marc une remontée
maintenant et la réalité on va voir
quand ça sera stabilisé non moi je dis
simplement qu'il faut qu'il faut dire
que sur le fait d'être un taux
d'imposition moyen je crois qu'on peut
tous être satisfait de cela pour la
compétitivité des deux entreprises bon
avec 25%, ça a été décidé de longue date
et ça a été mis en œuvre par le
gouvernement conformément à ce qui avait
été souhaité c'est bien maintenant en
tirer des réflexions trop lourdes entre
le fait de savoir si c'est ça qui permet
d'avoir plus de produits ou si
simplement la baisse des taux fait que
finalement si on avait eu un taux plus
important on aurait eu un produit plus
important bah c'est très difficile de se
faire une religion si je peux me
permettre sur ce sujet mais non mais je
laisse le ministre sans doute me dire à
peu près l'inverse
ouais c'est un débat qu'on a souvent
avec le président rénal effectivement là
moi je vous rejoins c'est que il faudra
quelques années pour mesurer pleinement
les effets et arriver à une position
convergente ce qui est certain c'est que
l'an dernier on a eu une année où
l'impôt sur les sociétés avaient un taux
historiquement faible 25% et on a eu des
recettes historiquement oste donc ça
c'est juste factuel il peut y avoir
différents effets vous l'avez dit mais
je pense qu'on est en train en tout cas
j'espère je crois profondément qu'on est
en train de faire la démonstration que
quand vous taxez moins un gâteau qui
grossit vous recevez plus que quand vous
surtaxé un gâteau qui rétrécit parce que
vous le surtaxé si je devais imaginer
les choses de manière un peu peut-être
caricatural oui il faut pas que ça fonde
comme une glace me dit le rapporteur
général c'est vrai mais en tout cas
voilà on a eu davantage de recettes
et pour autant en baissant un certain
nombre d'impôts notamment qui pèsent sur
les entreprises on devient pas un
paradis fiscal on reste quand même le
pays qui a le deuxième taux de
prélèvement obligatoire sur les 38 pays
de l'OCDE derrière le Danemark mais je
pense que c'est toujours important de le
dire y compris y compris en supprimant
la CVAE y compris en baissant l'impôt
sur les sociétés
ah mais tout le monde non
mais oui mais je veux dire tout le monde
non mais tout le monde paye plus en
France que chez nos voisins quel que
soit le niveau de contribuable et moi je
voudrais qu'on arrête de dire que la
France est un paradis fiscal c'est pas
le cas y compris les contribuables les
plus fortunés non mais quand vous quand
vous entendez quand vous entendez
certains débats y compris les
contribuables les plus fortunés on est
le dernier pays européen à avoir un
impôt national sur la fortune on a un
taux marginal à 45% avec une
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
hauts revenus qui avait été mis en place
pour être temporaire ça fait 13 ans
qu'elle existe ce qui fait un taux
marginal autour de 49% on a une CSG
progressif je veux dire je pense que
c'est toujours important de rappeler les
choses je dis pas ça pour le critiquer
je pense qu'il y a encore certains
impôts qu'on peut baisser mais en tout
cas ça permet de le rappeler sur des
traits d'avance mais à faire
effectivement désolé je vous avais pas
répondu à ce stade nous ne prévoyons pas
qu'il soit nécessaire d'avoir un décret
d'avance ou un PLFR autre que le PLFR de
fin de gestion j'espère que ce sera le
cas jusqu'à la fin de l'année qui aura
pas de d'éléments supplémentaires de
crise qui justifierait qu'on doit en
passer par là mais à ce stade ça n'est
pas prévu il est dépenses
supplémentaires qui sera nécessaire au
regard de la situation géopolitique vous
avez cité les armées avec 1,5 milliards
d'euros pour être régularisés en fin de
gestion je rappelle que le ministère des
armées a une marche de 3 milliards
d'euros cette année qui permet
évidemment
d'absorber un certain nombre de de
dépenses sur pardon pour la dernière
question sur les recettes fiscales je
vais demander à mon équipe qu'on
réévalue mais sur l'année
2022 l'estimation qu'on avait eu en fin
d'année dernière c'est que le surcroît
de taxes lié à la hausse des prix du
carburant était autour de 3,5 à 4
milliards d'euros je rappelle que
l'aristo on a coûté le double donc
l'état ne s'est pas enrichi face à
l'inflation notamment sur l'énergie
quand on regarde toutes les dépenses qui
ont été consenties notamment pour mettre
en place le bouclier sur les prix de
l'électricité et du gaz le guichet pour
les entreprises les aides ou PME et au
TPE la ristourne sur le carburant
aujourd'hui
l'aide carburant on a dépensé beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on a reçu en surcroît de
taxes sur l'énergie liée à l'inflation
et maintenant je crois que je finis en
séance publique pour un débat
oui mais comme nous avons fini avec des
questions moi je suis à votre
disposition peut rester mais merci en
tout cas monsieur le ministre pour pour
votre venue et votre présentation et
donc effectivement nous allons nous
retrouver pour ceux qui le souhaitent
évidemment pour le débat qui va avoir le
je crois 18h45 l'horaire a été fixé à
18h45
quelle réponse au phénomène de fois de
fiscale aux dividendes alors phénomène
mondialisé un de fraude fiscale aux
dividendes donc à 18h45 en séance où
nous vous retrouvons monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup merci à tous